[Music]
tiffany is with us tiffany's in seattle
hi tiffany how are you
good dave hi chris hi dave how are you
great how can we help
um so my husband and i are having a hard
time getting to the 15
uh for retirement um and um so my
husband
um his company let them put up to 18 000
a year in there and then i for
myself for work um they take 12 of my
income
and um but we still don't get to the 15
because we make about 250 000 a year
and so we are wondering if my husband is
not very comfortable
putting money in the stock market and i
don't know why he
he doesn't want to do a roth ira because
he feels
he thinks it's connected to the market
and what's he putting what's he putting
his 401k in
well that's the thing uh his 401k is
connected and that he feels that that is
enough since he's putting 18
technically eighteen thousand dollars in
there a year
you can put um 000 in but if you put 26
000 in all of a sudden the market's a
bad idea
it's completely alive exactly i
completely agree but he does not
he doesn't feel comfortable putting
money in
and so i'm thinking that maybe if he
doesn't want to do that
can we buy investment property instead
and technically we're starting
still investing that money but it's not
through the market
would that still be okay
um no because your decision-making
skills are broken
okay and if you can't make good solid
critical thinking skill decisions on
your investing you're going to
use the same broken system to buy real
estate with
and um i mean so at what point does real
estate become risky
past 500 000 past a million or just
short of 10 million
where is real estate risky and so right
you know you have to be able to look at
things logically and work your way
through them
um so no i i think you need i think you
guys need to
talk this through and uh
and figure out what it is that makes uh
26 000 by the way he can do nineteen
thousand this year not just eighteen
thousand is his max
but um at what point does it become
risky
uh that putting in nineteen thousand
versus putting in twenty five thousand
yeah and dave and i'm gonna tell you
this
you know just re reminder tiffany you
know
for us if you go to invest in real
estate we're talking about you're doing
a hundred percent down honey
right and so all that money that you got
to have money to be able to do that so
he he's got something going on and i
think talking about it and figuring it
out
the goal is again to you all to have
enough money to be able to live your
dreams later
and so i would talk about those high
definition dreams all over again
about what it is you all want to do the
charities you want to give to the things
you want to go do as a family and then
try to re re-engineer reverse engineer
that
and look to see does this get you closer
to where it is you want to be
yeah as far as the market goes what
helps me a lot with
investing in stock market and mutual
funds is
to understand and know the history so
sit down with a smart vester pro and let
them
look and show let them walk you through
like with this mutual fund
it's 80 years old here's what has
happened when the market did this and
the market did that
here's what happened in 2008 here's what
happened when the in
1957 when the russians launched sputnik
and the stock market went down
uh they beat us into space right so the
stock market went down there's all these
little events in history
global events that caused the stock
market to go down and there's other
events that cause it to go up
and so you can look at that and the more
you understand okay here was the actual
mathematical variance not the emotions
but here was the mathematical variance
and here's exactly what
really occurred and um
the more you understand that the more
you're really analyzing the risk then
and then if he's not comfortable then it
would be logical only to not put
any money in ah
that would be the thing and if you can
say that then then i
okay i hate the stock market i only want
to do real estate
okay i can go with that let's save it
but 18 000 is is all the risk i can
stand but 25 000 isn't that
when i make 250 a year it's flawed math
dave completely illogical
this is the dave ramsey show